[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
tag der video berichterstattung vom
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos heute
wieder an meiner seite sven astheimer
unser ressortleiter im unternehmens
ressort faz es wenn jetzt ist ja schon
donnerstag und sind schon die ganze
woche da wenn du eine zwischenbilanz
oder eigentlich schon fast eine
abschlussbilanz ziehen möchte ist von
davos was sind so deine deine
wichtigsten eindrücke die duh
mitgenommen hat und was ist der
vielleicht auch also sagen wir mal
einmal witziges und einmal wichtiges
passiert wichtig ist hier auf jeden fall
passiert in dem über themen der zukunft
geredet wurde
digitalisierung gerade mobilität war ein
schwerpunkt viele panels die sich darum
treten wie kommen wir morgen von a nach
b und verbunden mit einem anderen thema
nämlich tun wir das auch ressourcen
schonen und umweltbewusst also diese
beiden themen haben hier einen ganz
großen schwerpunkt gespielt wenn man
schaut was in langfristige themen wie
gehen wir das an big data
datensicherheit ebenfalls einen punkt du
hast ja viele panel selbst besucht
persönlich hat man auch einige
interessante und teilweise auch witzige
begegnungen ich hatte heute ein treffen
mit zwei mobile spezialisten der eine
nico rosberg frühere formel 1
weltmeister der in der autoentwicklung
unterwegs ist und hier auch einer der
young global leaders das sind junge
leute denen man zutraut ist die zukunft
an entscheidender stelle mitgestalten
war sehr interessant und dabei auch
bundesverkehrsminister andreas scheuer
der hier natürlich ganz viele experten
gefunden habe um sich mit denen über die
zukunftsweisenden themen in der
mobilitäts frage und zu unterhalten und
die waren beide relativ angetan ein
bisschen geschafft wie das am ende von
da wo es auch durchaus legitim ist aber
zufrieden ja so das waren meine
eindrücke von diesem jahr
es gab heute aber ja auch noch ein
bisschen politische news der
österreichische bundeskanzler kurz war
hier gewesen
also das ist natürlich schon sehr stark
das thema europa das den
österreichischen bundeskanzler hier auch
um betrieben hat ohnehin ja neben den
von dir genannten punkten eine der ganz
großen fragen hier wie stellen wir uns
in europa so wenige tage vor einem
potenziellen drexhage auf da hat er noch
wiederholt leute gibt den dritten mehr
zeit wir müssen um den heartbreakers auf
jeden fall darum herumkommen wenn es
irgendwie geht bis zur europawahl sei
schon noch zeit die sollten sich die
briten nehmen ansonsten war es ein
plädoyer für ein selbstbewusstes europa
das nicht übereinander redet und sagt
die polen sind irgendwie doof und die
ungarn auch und wir sind moralisch von
einer höheren warte und können über die
richten nach solcher sagt lass das doch
mal sein ja damit macht man die
europäische idee kaputt
tretet mal wieder selbstbewusster auf
und und besinnt euch auf eure stärken
gründet unternehmen und seid mal wieder
ein bisschen anspruchsvoller auch
gegenüber euch selbst ich fand seinen
auftritt eindrucksvoll muss ich sagen es
hat ein sehr junger mann 32 jahre alt
und redet mit den leuten schon natürlich
ganz anders als eine angela merkel die
wir am vortag gehört haben und ein
mobilitäts thema habe ich heute auch
noch mit begleiten dürfen herbert diess
der vorstandsvorsitzende von volkswagen
ist auch hier
und der hat was ganz interessantes
gesagt nämlich elektromobilität ist ganz
klar das ist eigentlich schon abgehakt
das kommt und mit voller kraft und es
kommt auch eher als eine brennstoffzelle
die nämlich im zweifel in effizient ist
also eher setzt voll auf
elektromobilität
aber die nächste große herausforderung
ist schon da nämlich das aus volkswagen
den software-konzern wird da müssen die
unbedingt ran wie so viele andere
deutsche autohersteller auch das ist
nach seinen worten das produkt das
komplizierteste produkt das künftig mit
dem internet verbunden sein wird
ja und dann müssen die deutschen
natürlich ganz schön ja wie sagt man
denn eigentlich künftig gas geben oder
ampere erklärungen strom geben ja genau
darum geht's ja und das dass das sind
auch zwei also eigentlich haben sich
heute noch mal zwei sehr wichtige
systeme unter einem brennglas dann
gespiegelt ja du sagst es also das thema
wie geht man mit diesen unmengen von
daten um das zieht sich ja eigentlich
auch fast durch jede konferenz und nicht
umsonst hat der japanische premier habe
gekündigt den usa gipfel der g20 unter
dieses motto zu stellen wie gehen wir
mit den daten um welches regime wollen
wir weltweit am besten einführen damit
mehr einheitlichkeit haben es wird alle
noch weiter beschäftigen
foto gabe brecht gesagt hast gab er
heute auch hier eine andere geschichte
eigentlich hätte der britische
finanzminister hammond philip hammond
auf einem podium teilnehmen müssen und
immer hat wohl die zusammensetzung und
das thema nicht so gefallen denn es wäre
wahrscheinlich eine europa diskussion
geworden und über die aufgrund seines
unmutes hat es dann vorgezogen nicht
teilzunehmen das ist für jemanden wir
haben und der eigentlich als davos
nennen gilt
und hier in den vergangenen jahren
erlebt sehr gelöst und locker unterwegs
war ein klares zeichen dass man in
großbritannien und in london jetzt
wirklich unter enormem druck steht
ja man merkt schon liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer dass es in der welt ganz
schön was los ist die absagen
über die wir ganz am anfang schon
besprochen gesprochen haben von von
trump von makro von den briten die
spielen hier schon eine große rolle
bis in den letzten tag hinein und ja man
kann eigentlich nur die hoffnung nehmen
hier beim sonnenschein von davos
dass sich so die eine oder andere dunkle
wolke doch bitte wieder verziehen möge
danke dass wir die ganze zeit mit
zugeschaut haben wir freuen uns über ihr
interesse und sagen einfach mal bis zum
nächsten jahr in davos ist an
[Musik]